look I gotta gibberish oh yeah my juju
is ot open maybe I shall enjoy
found this game also a coffee regulate
know at the time I should the Catalan so
thirsty I've always liked vote nice to
see you Jerry
I like you came through here I was
inspired by Lumiere jewel you just tell
me go to all shine I'm saying is anybody
know about Jude I thought anybody can
make your Giri I'm sad so I just made it
happen
shut up meet Rashad our son it's a part
of your image yeah book if he shows just
like yours man okay I think I hate more
I had another choker it was 15 points
my sister lost it he was so crazy she
told me out to like three months she's
like hanging out of ten I'm like the
piece of I'm going materialize I
wouldn't get mad at you for nothing
all the salty I had another 3.3 or ring
my time to roll on a young thug gave me
on my birthday my birthday in nineteen I
lost it like the 21st I left an uber
uber driver you found my ring and [ __ ]
you up
no that's your tip man go hey you said
your life AP well I got it from easy to
jewel based on first watch the Rolex
[Music]
like in the roadie I get the first road
yeah hey get it was probably like 20 who
managed me mad at me robbed the glass
you go get it again i down my kids roll
he's all I'm taking
[Music]
705 Gramps
[Music]
85 Rallo hit the bugs out queuing all
choclo he really gave me the idea to
happen
I base it off the outfit son I like
stuck it on sometimes like a headache so
I ride the level it up like like this
boy oh boy oh boy my acne hate putting
all of it on cuz it take a long time so
I sleep it's a [ __ ] I hate like fangs
a buzz now bang it was my first time one
I kept putting my pocket no look at my
jogger pants my name is gone
see I love three gonna ring twenty like
twenty three thousand oh my god from
icebox based out of Atlanta we call
itself 200 the whole chief keef little
sense anyways I'm saying so I made it to
a ring
okay everybody making it to change Cuban
link ring we got this from busy and then
mistake it was like 6,500 through a
wedding ring just like we're on the same
amount we've got this from all ice box
it was like around all right like 6700
same thing with this 6700 oh god forget
diamonds in it I don't really like Cuba
ring I a guy because I have two Cuban
bracelets the Cuban braces I got all
three of them at the same time I got it
from Izzy smaller to be like 13 what
time is it
[Music]
Tarkio crazy this was 30 finds out I got
this icebox
based out of a lotta good coffee Tokyo
sure sit these off get any funny jokes I
got these involve easy they are the same
size they always like 17,000 apiece
[Music]
I'm gonna get another Cuban I wanted
like stacked on top of each other I'm
gonna get some more opinions creative
Phineas yeah I definitely got him on my
jammy shirt I start looting out a jury
made me do shout-out GQ I'm stamping the
fan for a long time I'm saying I'm
honored to deer show off the Jerry I'm
saying hey all my presence sounds to the
streets three I'm just dropping off
salmon stream everyone go get it shut up